le gigantesque chantier ne dort jamais
mis tes jours les travailleurs creuse
déplace la terre et les blocs de pierre
près par le dynamitage
plusieurs d'entre eux sont loin de leur
foyer ça fait 22 ans que je fais ce
chantier j'ai tout fait les gens ne
râlent pas mal depuis à son tour
cet ouvrage est différent la romaine 4
est un chantier imprévisible c'est
certain que le projet romaine 4 on a eu
plusieurs difficultés causées par la
géologie
donc on a rencontré une roche qui était
à très friands il y a deux ans un
travailleur a péri lors de
l'effondrement d'une partie de la paroi
rocheuse
depuis la santé et la sécurité sont
devenus une obsession
chaque quart de travail commence par un
rappel des consignes à suivre
le chef de chantier stéphane gens ont
fait une affaire personnelle et à aucun
impératif d'échéancier qui va prédominer
sur la sécurité des travailleurs
pour certains le futur barrage marque la
fin d'une époque qui a connu la
construction des plus grandes oeuvres de
la société d'état pendant 75 ans manik
la grande outarde sont quelques-unes des
62 centrale qui frappe encore
l'imaginaire propulsé par des
politiciens tels que rené lévesque et
robert bourassa qui ont voulu que les
québécois prennent les rênes de leur
production d'électricité et deviennent
maîtres chez eux
environ 75% des résidences au québec ce
chauffage au mazout et avec la hausse du
prix du pétrole évidemment ça ça me
frapper droit et à une conversion très
rapide vers le vers l'électrique le
québec entre dans l'ère moderne et les
barrages deviennent des fourmilières des
dizaines de milliers de travailleurs qui
oeuvrent hydro québec devient un
imposant réseau fournisseurs
d'électricité verte
c'est un immense succès pour le québec
au total dans son ensemble mais là et
misère en même temps les relations avec
les régions et les communautés
régionales et en plus on va les appeler
comme ça les nations autochtones
ça c'est plus difficile quand tu
regardes et tu es si les cris ont pu
bénéficier d'entente telles que la paix
des braves
d'autres nations se sentent encore
laissés pour compte en haut des ententes
qui ne sont pas nécessairement
avantageux malgré qu'on travaille très
fort lorsque vous voyez les profits
records qui est du québec fait pour le
grand match québec et que nous recevons
des on peut dire des miettes les régions
de leur côté décrit la mainmise du siège
social de montréal sur la bouche de trop
vu leurs trompes eu à la romaine 4 les
autochtones les nord côtiers qui
représentent respectivement 10 % et 50 %
de la main-d'oeuvre travaillent et
vivent côte à côte dans l'immense
campement c'est maintenant l'utilité de
la centrale qui est mise en cause
car plus que jamais hydro-québec nage
dans les surplus notamment parce que la
demande croît plus lentement
on a lancé la romaine et avec l'idée que
peut-être qu'on pourrait exporter
davantage
oui en export mais les prix sont
tellement faibles que ça ne justifie pas
les développement hydroélectrique pour
vendre à ces prélats d'ici un an ce
chantier fera place au dernier barrage
du vaste complexe hydroélectrique de la
romaine
et puis après est ce que ce sera le
dernier grand ouvrage d'hydro-québec
jusqu'à nouvel ordre oui un nouveau
barrage serait difficile à justifier vu
l'ampleur des surplus de la société
d'état mais la donne pourrait changer
dans quelques années ici maxime bertrand
au chantier de la romaine 4 au nord de
havre-saint-pierre